en un vídeo anterior encontramos una
forma de multiplicar un número de dos
dígitos por un número de un dígito lo
que hicimos fue descomponer el número de
dos dígitos en términos de sus valores
posicional es el 3 de aquí son tres
decenas estas son siete unidades si
vemos 37 6 es es lo mismo que 36 es 3
decenas por 6 7 6 6 7 x 6 y sumamos
ambas para tener un total de 222 lo que
haremos en este vídeo es ver qué ocurre
cuando multiplicamos un número de dos
dígitos por otro número de dos dígitos
ahora vamos a resolver 37 y en lugar de
multiplicarlo por 6 lo multiplicamos por
26 otra forma de pensar en ello es que
queremos calcular 37-26 es así que pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo vean
si pueden usar una forma similar a la
que usamos antes para hacerlo una forma
de pensar en esto es que
estos son 37 26 es o podemos verlo como
37 66 37 20 primero podemos hacer los 37
6 es que es exactamente lo que hicimos
aquí y podemos hacerlo en cualquier
orden primero hagamos 36 es
multiplicamos 30 por 6 que es 180 esto
es 3 decenas por 6 y ahora calculamos 7
unidades por 6 que es igual a 42 esto es
7 unidades por 6 o 7 6 es y hacemos lo
mismo con los veintes podemos decir oye
a que es igual tres decenas por dos o
treinta veintes es igual a 6 por 10 por
10 vamos a escribirlo son tres decenas
por dos decenas es lo que estamos
haciendo aquí y esto es lo mismo que 30
por 20 que es igual a 3 por 2 por 2 10
es que es 10 por 10 esto es 6 centenas
lo escribimos aquí y para que quede
claro ya habíamos pensado en cuánto es
76 es que son estos números de aquí y
que aún tenemos que sumar pero ahora
pensemos en 37 20 así que primero
pensamos en 30 20 es que 600 y ahora
vamos a pensar en 720 720 eso es 7 por 2
es 14 por lo que 7 por 20 es 140 que son
7 unidades por dos decenas o 720 es
ahora podemos sumar todo esto para
calcular el total y para hacerlo es
bueno tenerlos ordenados por su valor
posicional vemos la posición de las
unidades y vemos que hay un total de 2
unidades ahora sumamos las decenas 8
decenas más 4 decenas son 12 decenas más
otras cuatro decenas son 16 decenas y 16
decenas podemos descomponer las como una
centena y seis decenas por lo que
escribimos aquí las seis decenas y
acá arriba ponemos la centena una
centena más otras centenas son dos
centenas más seis centenas son ocho
centenas más otra centena es igual a
nueve centenas aquí lo tenemos es igual
a 962 y de verdad quiero que comprendan
lo que hicimos aquí aunque luce un poco
complicado primero calculamos cuánto es
37 6 es lo que nos dio estos números de
aquí que son los mismos que calculamos
en un vídeo anterior y después
calculamos cuánto es 37 20 es que es de
donde salieron estos otros números de
hecho vamos a escribirlo todo esto que
en se rellenan naranja 2 es 37 6 es 37
por 6 y esto de acá abajo es 37 20 es 37
por 20 si esto no les parece obvio pausa
en el vídeo o repasen los reflexionen
sobre esto e intenten hacerlo con otros
números ya que si comprenden bien esto
su vida con las multiplicaciones e
incluso su vida con las matemáticas
se volverá cada vez más intuitiva